[Musique]
bonsoir à toutes et à tous bienvenue
dans le 7 8 votre quotidienne sur TV 78
avec nos chroniqueurs et nos invités
nous allons parcourir l'information dans
les Yvelines nous sommes le lundi 26
juin voici le sommaire
y a-t-il une crise du logement dans le
département des Yvelines la question se
pose à l'heure actuelle une évolution
symptomatique de ce phénomène semble
confirmer la situation la construction
de logements neuf baisse de 40% par
rapport à 2022 nous ferons le poids avec
Angel Dupont directrice de la DEAL
journée olympique au Golf National
présentation du parcours de la flamme
olympique dans les Yvelines les Jeux
olympiques de Paris 2024 approche à
grands pas mais les Yvelinois doivent
encore patienter un peu plus d'un an
alors quels sont les prochains
rendez-vous à Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines
d'ici à ce rendez-vous mondial nous
verrons avec notre invité et enfin le
vélo Drôme national à trembler au rythme
des poids des voies et de la force
envoyée tout le week-end le French
strawdown se tenait ce vendredi jusqu'à
dimanche c'était au Vélodrome national
un événement qui a rassemblé 9000
participants de CrossFit Michael
[Musique]
c'est un joueur d'abord qui a un
parcours il a il a été dans la grande
équipe de Nanterre c'est une première
chose il a également une carrière
nationale qui est tout à fait tout à
fait intéressante
et puis je pense que tout à l'heure nous
allons pouvoir l'apprécier directement
et je pense que la meilleure
présentation c'est encore par lui-même
je trouve que personnellement c'est un
garçon qui est d'une modestie et d'une
courtoisie tout à fait remarquable ce
qui n'est pas toujours le cas
effectivement parce que alors il y aura
bien évidemment bien évidemment
jérémyzoni qui sera avec tout en visio
et puis il y aura aussi STEVE et Sarre
le coach de l'équipe de basketball de
Trappes avec nous un invité olympique
Arnaud courtier bonsoir bonsoir alors
conseiller spécial Jeux olympiques et
paralympiques pour Saint-Quentin en
Yvelines la relation civiloise et 56
elle est à quel niveau en ce moment
elle monte gentiment chez nous parce que
on travaille on prépare et on sent qu'on
approche même s'il reste une année mais
on le voit sur les événements qu'on
organise avec tous les gens qu'on croise
qui sont enthousiaste et qui sont
impatients aussi donc voilà ça monte
3806 jours des Jeux olympiques du début
des Jeux Olympiques Paris 2024 enfin
nous sommes aussi accompagnés d'un
journaliste et de la journaliste de la
rédaction Céline Charles bonsoir avec
vous on va revenir sur les informations
du jour ce sera juste après la météo
tout de suite
[Musique]
et demain matin le ciel yvelinois sera
en partie voilée avec quelques
éclaircies à avoir dans la matinée les
températures seront déjà chaudes avec 17
degrés dans la partie nord et centrale
du département et 16 degrés dans le sud
des Yvelines dans l'après-midi même
prévisions par rapport à la matinée les
nuages seront toujours présents mais le
soleil fera quelques apparitions côté
température il fera 24 degrés à
Mantes-la-Jolie Houdan et Rambouillet
puis 23 degrés à Versailles et demain on
fêtera les ferments et tout de suite les
informations du jour
[Musique]
et on commence par cette information ces
lignes une partie du département des
Yvelines a été placée en alerte
sécheresse oui la pluie semble avoir
pris des vacances dans le département
les quelques précipitations demi-juin
n'ont pas réussi en digue la sécheresse
la préfecture a donc décidé vendredi
dernier de renforcer son arrêt la zone
sud-est du département et passer en
situation d'alerte elle concerne 38
communes dont notamment celle de
Saint-Quentin en Yvelines la zone centre
reste en situation d'alerte renforcée et
les zones cèdent saines et Sud-Ouest en
situation de vigilance les habitants
sont appelés à adopter des comportements
responsables et des mesures de
restriction des usages de l'eau ont été
prises pour les collectivités
particuliers et entreprises par exemple
l'arrosage est interdit entre 11h et 18h
le lavage des véhicules personnels et le
remplissage des piscines et proscrit
également vous pouvez consulter le site
du département pour plus de détails et
le site qui s'affiche en bas de l'écran
et comme chaque été la SNCF réalise des
travaux sur ces lignes le trafic va être
impacté alors qu'elles sont les lignes
concernées Céline et oui Nicolas avec
les départs en vacances le réseau
ensuite pour ce moderniser et faire de
la maintenance dans les Yvelines aucune
des cercles ne sera supprimée pour le
RER C pour la ligne u peu de changements
seuls les week-ends du 12 au 27 août
seront impactés le trafic sera supprimé
entre Paris La Défense et Suresnes
impactant la liaison avec Chaville
Versailles trappes
Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines et la verrière
l'usage de la ligne L est à privilégier
pour la ligne N aucun train ne circulera
entre les gardes Plaisir-Grignon et
Mantes-la-Jolie du 8 juillet au 13 août
début de substitution devrait remplacer
les desserts de supprimer d'autres
lignes du département sont concernées
notamment le RERA et les lignes JL du
Transilien rendez-vous sur le site de la
SNCF pour plus de détails également une
fois il est en bas de l'écran et alors
un mot d'emploi maintenant et oui alors
ce mardi 27 juin de 14h à 17h le job
truck sera présent au gymnase Jean Macé
à Saint-Cyr-l'École alors si vous
cherchez un emploi une formation ou bien
une aide à la création d'entreprise
d'associations d'insertion
professionnelle CBL réagir sera là pour
vous conseiller et vous informer
autre information fait divers un combat
de boxe de rue a été interdit par la
préfecture ce week-end à Mantes-la-Jolie
pour le club de boxe de canal pour ce
dimanche ce club associatif prévoyait un
événement de street Street Fight au Val
fourrées une compétition non-officielle
qui permet de faire combattre selon les
règles de la box plusieurs personnes à
travers le quartier le combat a été
interdit par la préfecture des Yvelines
dans un communiqué de presse et la
souligner le caractère non autorisé et
non déclaré de cette rencontre mais
surtout sa dangerosité si elle n'est pas
encadrée par des professionnels et un
dispositif médical adapté une
information insolite maintenant au
château de Versailles qui a fait l'objet
d'un défilé de mode mais un peu
particulier et oui c'est ça alors la
marque Jacques muse je ne sais pas si
vous la connaissez allez célèbres
notamment pour ses sacs et bien les
réputés aussi pour nous embarquer dans
les plus beaux recoins de France et la
présenter sa collection le chouchou lors
d'un défilé de mode cet après-midi c'est
le somptueux château de Versailles et
ses jardins qui lui ont servi deux
décors pour cette occasion de nombreuses
stars ont fait le déplacement dont la
célèbre actrice américaine Eva Longoria
elle a pu visiter le château et admirer
le défilé une destination qui lui a
visiblement plus si on se assez
nombreuses publications sur le château
sur ses réseaux sociaux et on termine
avec des week-end de fête c'était la
Saint Jean ce weekend et la ville d'elle
en cours a eu sa fête exactement
l'occasion de se retrouver entre voisins
entre amis ou en famille jeux de société
parcours gonflables défis sportives
activités manuelles ou encore balade
aponée de nombreux animations pour tous
les âges étaient organisés toute
l'après-midi au stade André Boniface un
rendez-vous annuel important pour les
habitants et les élus de la ville
écoutez ce super cool franchement ça
fait super plaisir il y a plein de jeux
pour deux enfants franchement ça fait
super plaisir avec cette chaleur c'est
un peu dur mais on est là on est heureux
de faire plaisir aux enfants et on est
heureux que la ville nous fasse plaisir
à son tour ça permet de rencontrer pas
mal de monde c'est assez convivial de
rencontrer les parents avec qui nos
enfants sont scolarisés et puis ça
permet de discuter et puis de passer un
bon moment quoi d'abord il redécouvre
tous les sports qui sont pratiqués
Élancourt ils découvrent tous les enjeux
aussi des Jeux Olympiques qui vont être
un événement enfin sur 10 ans c'est
fait une fois par siècle c'est en même
temps toutes les valeurs du sport qui
sont les mêmes valeurs qui font gagner
c'est c'est un peu de rigueur c'est
l'entraînement c'est la détermination et
les festivités se sont prolongés
jusqu'au bout de la nuit avec un grand
concert plusieurs guestars ont fait
danser les Yvelines Patrick Hernandez
l'interprète de Born to Be Alive le
groupe début de soirée Pedro Castagno
célèbre pour la Macarena ou encore
claire DL5 on a du bien danser du côté
d'Élancourt ce week-end merci Céline
Charles de rien Nicolas si vous voyez
une information et bien n'hésitez pas à
nous la partager sur les réseaux sociaux
avec le hashtag 7 8 news
[Musique]
si vous cherchez une maison ou un
appartement dans les Yvelines vous
l'avez sans doute déjà remarqué il est
de plus en plus compliqué de se loger
dans le département une situation qui
tend à s'aggraver à ce sujet Mathilde
Franco a reçu Angel Dupont directrice de
l'ADIL 78 l'Agence départementale
d'information sur le logement des
Yvelines regardez
[Musique]
c'est de plus en plus compliqué de
trouver un logement dans les Yvelines
près de cette yvelinois sur 10 ont du
mal à trouver un appartement ou une
maison dans le département un chiffre
conséquent et la situation n'est pas
prête de s'améliorer selon les acteurs
du secteur pour en parler avec nous
Angèle Dupont bonsoir ça alors vous êtes
la directrice de l'ADIL c'est l'agence
départementale d'informations sur le
logement des Yvelines alors première
question un constat comment est-ce qu'il
expliquez-vous cette situation dans le
département cette crise du logement tout
simplement parce que le département est
un ascendant poids et de services assez
conséquent comme comme toutes
l'Île-de-France qui attirent des
personnes venant de tous les
départements alentours et même parfois
un peu plus loin sauf que par conséquent
faut se loger c'est déjà une croissance
démographique trop conséquente et puis
oui un mouvement plutôt qu'autre chose
puisque une croissance
des personnes originales du territoire
mais c'est vraiment une un flux de
personnes venant des territoires
limitrophes pour travailler que du coup
arriver à un moment ils en ont marre de
faire les allers-retours entre leur lieu
de travail et leur domicile et souhaite
se rapprocher du coup en cherchant sur
le territoire est-ce que c'est dû aussi
à la difficulté aujourd'hui de
construire de nouveaux logements
ah c'est sûr que c'est une des raisons
parce qu'on a deux problématiques le
parc privé le parc social et c'est une
des raisons qui bloque au niveau du parc
social c'est qu'on a pu le foncer
nécessaire aujourd'hui pour continuer de
créer autant que nos besoins le
demandent alors au niveau des chiffres
le département enregistre une baisse de
44% dans la construction de logements
neufs par rapport à 2022 comment est-ce
que vous expliquez ce ce chiffre
pourquoi on ne construit plus de
logements neufs dans le département
parce qu'il y a plus de fonciers
disponibles on a quand même exploité pas
mal de choses il est de plus en plus
cher et
ça va pas l'air on s'arrangeant
puisqu'on va sur de l'artification
0 donc en limitant réellement notre
impact sur l'environnement et en
limitant du coup la construction en
construisant différemment peut-être en
élevant plutôt que en ces temps alors
justement quels sont les solutions pour
pallier à tous ces problèmes bah déjà
rénové notre date existant pour lui
donner plus de plus de cachets et
répondre à des normes environnementales
autant que sanitaire et puis bah du coup
repenser l'architecture ça c'est le
travail de d'association ou de conseils
comme le CAE qui vont du coup
accompagner sur de la substitution
nouvelle avec du coup la surélévation de
plus en plus attractive aussi bien dans
de la copropriété privée que dans du
parc social et vous au sein de l'ADIL du
coup comment est-ce que vous aidez les
personnes
concrètement à retrouver un logement ou
à trouver un logement tout court alors
du coup nous on va plus intervenir sur
le biais du parc social puisque sur le
parc privé à part leur énoncé le champ
des possibles et le fait que les agences
demandent aujourd'hui trois fois le
montant du loyer en terme de ressources
ce qui bloque on va plutôt œuvrer sur
l'accès au parc social qui est un droit
en fonction de ces ressources puisque
c'est conditionné à des placements
ressources mais du coup il y a selon les
derniers chiffres de la préfecture
publiée sur leur site 48000 demandeurs
de logements sur notre territoire avec
un taux de rotation de logement de 1400
c'est à dire qu'à 1400 logements qui se
libèrent donc forcément il y a un
problème donc nous on va les accompagner
pour faire des démarches pour rendre
leur demande prioritaire par le biais du
recours DALO donc le droit au logement
imposable pour que ça crée des
obligations de relogement au niveau du
département et alors quel est le délai
pour que ces personnes puissent
retrouver un logement on trouve un
logement alors le délai médian dans les
Yvelines serait de 17 mois et on estime
que c'est anormalement long quand on
attend depuis plus de 3 ans et la
situation elle
équivalente partout en France ou les
Yvelines sont particulièrement touchés
par cette crise du logement on va plutôt
dire les bassins d'emploi donc ça va
plutôt être l'Île-de-France à notre
niveau et puis après on va voir avec
toutes les grandes métropoles où ça
devient extrêmement difficile aussi de
se loger Bordeaux Marseille
Montpellier ce soir de choses mais après
c'est sûr qu'on a des poches d'air tout
autour de ces grandes régions où
métropole encore une fois sinon on fait
un pas sur le côté on va en or et en
Eure-et-Loir et on pourra se loger
beaucoup plus facilement mais ça demande
aussi de créer de l'infrastructure pour
pouvoir rejoindre son lieu de travail
beaucoup plus facilement aussi et
quelles sont les personnes les plus
touchées par cette situation on va voir
les familles monoparentales avec un seul
salaire pour pouvoir subvenir aux loyers
donc un parc privé quasiment impossible
à accéder et puis on a aussi tous les
jeunes ménage où les jeunes salariés qui
ont de faibles ressources pour commencer
ou qui sont en train de se lancer et qui
n'ont pas encore conclu leur CDI ou
un job plus plus rassurant pour le
propriétaire privé notamment et donc les
conseils que vous prodiguez ce sont
aussi bien pour les locataires que pour
ceux qui veulent devenir propriétaire
il y a de plus en plus d'accession aidés
sur le département des Yvelines
notamment par le biais de l'Office
foncier solidaire qui a été mis en place
par le Département puisqu'on sait que
c'est difficile d'acheter sur notre
territoire et du coup ils font de
l'accession à moindre coût en tout cas
40% moins cher et nous du coup on va
renseigner puisqu'on a un partenariat
avec le département on renseigne les
potentiels acquéreurs sur ce dispositif
on vérifie avec eux qui pourraient
prétendre et puis on essaye autant que
possible de faire de l'information ce
sens et donc elle a dit ils se sont
principalement des juristes qui
travaillent donc vous avez une mission
d'information mais aussi une mission
d'observation est-ce que vous pouvez
nous expliquer un petit peu quelles sont
vos différentes missions au sein de la
ville du coup notre mission principale
c'est de recevoir le public pour
l'informer de manière neutre gratuite et
si possible objective aussi bien le
propriétaire que le locataire et peu
importe le type de problème le droit
immobilier c'est très très vaste donc on
touche aussi bien l'accès au logement
dont on parle mais aussi les problèmes
entre les bailleurs et locataires
propriétés l'accession à la propriété ou
le gros sujet d'actualité la rénovation
énergétique et du coup nous on l'a on
les renseigne sur les droits sur leur
possibilité d'action et les oriente au
mieux pour que du coup ils puissent
derrière obtenir ou au moins tendre vers
ce sur quoi il souhaite aller et cette
mission d'observation elle prend la
forme plus du partenariat puisque nous
par toutes nos statistiques qu'on traite
toute l'année en rencontrant tout ce
public parce qu'on rencontre 10165
personnes sur l'année 2022 on en extrait
des typologies de ménage un type de
questions et du coup on peut alimenter
cette observatoire et alimenter un
partenariat riche avec les acteurs du
territoire qu'on va venir
renseigner par nos statistiques et bien
merci beaucoup Angel Dupont d'avoir
accepté notre invitation en plateau et
d'avoir répondu à nos questions si vous
souhaitez avoir plus d'informations sur
la DEAL vous pouvez vous rendre sur le
site internet qui s'affiche en bas de
votre écran
[Musique]
et comme chaque lundi on ouvre une page
sport dans le 7 8
[Musique]
j-396 avant la le début de la période
olympique en France d'abord avec les
Jeux olympiques du 26 juillet au 11 août
et les Jeux paralympiques du 28 août au
8 septembre pour patienter les
territoires concernés et bien font
monter un peu la sauce pour faire
patienter les habitants à travers des
événements ce week-end se tenait la
journée olympique organisée par
Saint-Quentin en Yvelines sur le futur
site olympique du Golf National au
programme découverte d'une trentaine de
sports et rencontre avec des athlètes un
reportage de Gabriel Gontier et de
Julien Leroy
[Musique]
il flottait comme un air de jeux
olympiques ce week-end au Golf National
de Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines les
personnes qui font les cours je compte
sur vous pour applaudir des athlètes
prenez je te laisse la parole pour
présenter le show de Tomlin à quelques
mois des JO 2024 une journée olympique
était organisée par la Communauté
d'Agglomération au programme
démonstration et découverte d'une
trentaine de sports parmi eux escalade
golf BMX ou encore tumbling une
discipline non olympique mais qui
appartient à la Fédération Française de
Gymnastique l'occasion de découvrir une
nouvelle discipline
du grand public donc moi mon but à long
terme c'est de pouvoir vraiment faire
connaître des disciplines que tout le
monde quand on parle de Tony on dit ah
oui je sais ce que c'est la connaissance
de ce sport a évolué dans mon but c'est
vraiment de démocratiser ce sport et
montrer que voilà c'est un sport à part
entière et qui peut qui peut être
pratiqué n'importe où Paris réussi pour
le la performance attire et impressionne
le public c'est vraiment impressionnant
c'est très très beau à regarder
toute la journée les visiteurs ont pu
échanger avec les sportifs et s'initier
aux différentes disciplines de quoi
susciter l'engouement des Yvelines à
l'approche des Jeux ah non des jeux je
sens un grand mouvement du public et des
50 chinois je le sens au quotidien par
un succès comme une journée comme
aujourd'hui mais je le sens également
par les nombreuses très nombreuses
candidatures au titre du volontariat
vous savez que Saint-Quentin a réussi à
négocier que Paris 2024 le fait de
réserver plus de 1000 postes pour les
volontaires issus du territoire et bien
nous avons aujourd'hui plus de 4 fois
plus de candidats que nous avons de
postes ouverts on a aux environs de
presque 5000 candidats qui se sont
portés volontaires pour rejoindre le
mouvement olympique à
Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines qui permet
donc de commencer à arriver et peut-être
de créer tes vocations chez des futurs
champions agit moins 396 de la cérémonie
d'ouverture
[Musique]
on vient de le voir sur l'image faite
partie de l'histoire dans un an 50 ans
en Yvelines fera partie de l'histoire de
l'olympisme avec nous toujours Arnaud
courtier conseiller spécial aux Jeux
olympiques et paralympiques pour 50 ans
en Yvelines quel bilan vous faites de 7
journées donc c'était samedi 24 juin ça
a commencé aussi vendredi avec les
écoles exactement vendredi c'était les
scolaires à peu près 700 enfants qui
étaient là et encore plus de monde le
samedi je crois qu'on était un peu plus
de 900 personnes qui qui sont venues
passer un moment ou un autre de la
journée donc un vrai succès moi j'ai
passé pas mal de temps sur site on avait
même organisé un footing de 5 km sur le
Golf National je remercie encore le
directeur du Golf National de fille
Philippe Pilato pardon de nous permettre
de faire tout ça chez lui on avait des
dossards à gagner pour les 10 km du dans
le cadre du marathon pour tous au jeu
une très bonne ambiance il faisait beau
il faisait chaud les gens ont découvert
plein de sport et ils sont tous
finalement très impatients effectivement
d'avoir les Jeux Olympiques sur le
territoire l'attente vous le sentez vous
allez vraiment présente et puis de plus
en plus de 50 chinois et 56 ont
conscience que ce sera vraiment
l'histoire qui s'écrir à 50 ans Yvelines
oui donc conscience que ce sera chez eux
on va de leur porte finalement on a vu
dans le reportage notre vice-président
le romazaury parlait du programme
bénévole du programme bénévole pour les
Jeux Olympiques dans les sites
olympiques il y aura aussi un programme
bénévole pour le territoire de
Saint-Quentin là encore on a beaucoup de
demandes mais ça tombe bien parce que on
a besoin que les gens nous aide et nous
accompagnent ça va être vraiment des des
grands moments de partage et ces jeux
les gens pourront les vide de toutes les
manières s'ils ont eu la chance d'avoir
un billet évidemment en allant assister
à des épreuves mais sur le territoire
ils verront aussi passer par exemple les
courses sur route masculines et
féminines de cyclisme mais ça c'est
gratuit c'est ouvert à tous comme le
Tour de France qui démarrera le 23
juillet pour sa dernière étape du
Vélodrome et puis nous organiserons
pendant les Jeux un espace de
célébration festif qui sera ouvert à
tous qui sera gratuit et tous les gens
pourront venir voir les épreuves sur des
écrans géants et profiter de nombreuses
animations justement vous faites la
transition avec le la date du 23 juillet
parce que et bien vendredi il y avait
aussi l'annonce du parcours de la flamme
olympique et elle sera le mardi 23
juillet 2020 24 dans les Yvelines le par
on se fera dans les Yvelines et
notamment au Golf National de
Saint-Quentin en Yvelines ça aussi ça se
prépare dès maintenant est-ce que vous
en savez un peu plus sur comment ça va
se dérouler alors on n'a pas encore tous
les détails on sait ça y est maintenant
que la flamme passera dans les Yvelines
heureusement elle passera dans je crois
plus de 400 villes en France sur 60
territoires et je crois qu'il y a à peu
près 10000 porteurs de flammes qui vont
se relayer donc déjà c'est
impressionnant et elle passera chez nous
elle passera sur le territoire elle
traversera le Golf National le passera
pas devant elle passera sur le golf ça
aussi c'est vraiment sympa comme clin
d'oeil pour pour ce site olympique on va
mettre en œuvre tout ça avec le
département avec le comité
d'organisation des Jeux Olympiques pour
que ce soit là encore la fête sur le
territoire 400 villes traversées par la
flamme est 64 villes étapes et je crois
que c'est 8 dans le dans le département
des Yvelines Michael ça va être une fête
qui va commencer même avant la cérémonie
d'ouverture le 26 juillet 2024 ah oui ça
va monter en puissance en toute façon
tout au cours de tout au long de cette
année et moi personnellement j'aimerais
bien porter la flamme à olympique sur le
territoire de 50 ans en Yvelines mais on
va voir
dans mon téléphone précisé mais je crois
que ce sont des relais de 200 mètres
donc c'est vraiment pour tout le monde
exactement le but c'est d'avoir beaucoup
de relayeurs qui représente la majorité
de la société tout simplement
vous en tant que président du club de
basket de Trappes je suppose que
l'impatience aussi règne dans dans votre
club
on est on attend avec beaucoup d'espoirs
les exploits de nos basketteurs bien sûr
c'était absolument évident si vous êtes
déjà fait aussi bien que la dernière
fois ce serait pas mal mais
pourquoi pas mieux on sait jamais
faire partie de cette équipe de France
lors des Jeux olympiques je regrette
qu'il puisse pas participer au
championnat du monde
il est vrai que c'est ces patrons
américains voient leurs priorité à eux
avant avant Arnaud a un mot sur les
épreuves qui vont se dérouler donc à
Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines je le rappelle
du 20 le 28 et 29 juillet ce sera le VTT
à la colline des lancaux le premier août
du 1er août au 4 août et du 7 août au 12
août c'est au golf national le 31
juillet et de août il y aura le BMX et
le 5 août du 5 août au 11 août le
cyclisme sur piste est-ce que 50 ans en
Yvelines va proposer peut-être des
places aux habitants pour aller voir
c'est ses compétitions alors je ne veux
pas donner trop d'espoir ou de faux
espoirs mais il se peut que nous
fassions gagner quelques places d'abord
donc c'est un suivi les réseaux sociaux
suivez les parutions de 50 ans en
Yvelines si je me trompe pas le VTT aura
des places gratuites si je me trompe pas
alors on a le 24 septembre un Test Event
sur la colline d'Élancourt VTT on va
voir quelques places pas beaucoup parce
qu'un Test Event c'est de plus petite
taille forcément effectivement là les
places sont gratuites on attend pas
encore les modalités dont je veux je ne
peux pas en dire plus pour l'instant
mais on va essayer d'en faire profiter
et effectivement les cinq continents
alors justement vous faites une
transition aussi avec les prochains
rendez-vous pour faire encore patienter
justement les 5 continents et 50
ninoises quels sont les prochains
rendez-vous vous venez de parler du 24
septembre sur avec un Test Event à la
colline des cours et ce qu'il y a
d'autres rendez-vous peut-être durant
l'été et même d'ici la fin de l'année
oui oui il y a plusieurs rendez-vous
d'abord on en a parlé tout à l'heure le
23 juillet le dimanche 23 juillet départ
de la dernière étape du Tour de France
au Vélodrome national c'est un spectacle
gratuit c'est le tour de France la
présentation des équipes le podium
signature se fera dans le vélo de Rome
donc on pourra venir dans le vélo de
rhum à si c'était à ça il y a une
billetterie pour ça mais elle est
gratuite c'est juste pour des raisons de
comptage et de sécurité qui ne
billetterie elle va ouvrir le 1er
juillet sur le site du Vélodrome
national et les gens pourront assister à
l'intérieur ou à l'extérieur à tout ce
qui va se passer toute la journée
le 24 septembre Test Event VTT en cours
c'est aussi la semaine de l'Open de
France au golf national en fin octobre
début novembre j'ai un trou de mémoire
ici Champions League au Vélodrome
national voilà la fin d'année comme le
début d'année prochaine sont jalonnés
d'événements sportifs importants
internationaux ou locaux aussi il y a du
sport toutes les semaines sur le
territoire avec les clubs de basket de
rugby de foot il se passe toujours des
choses mais on a des grands rendez-vous
jusqu'au Jeux Olympiques et ça ça permet
au territoire 50 ans en Yvelines de se
préparer aussi en terme de logistique en
termes de sécurité sur les différents
points qui accompagnent ce genre
d'événements exactement ce sont un petit
peu les dernières répétitions grandeur
nature le Test Event sur la colline
c'est parce que c'est un nouveau site on
ne l'a pas encore testé voilà donc il y
a un test qui sert aussi bien
sportivement que logistiquement tester
la billetterie électronique tester la
sécurité les plantes circulation tout ce
qu'on doit valider mais sur les autres
sites que sont le Golf National le vélo
de Rome national ou le BMX Stadium on
est plus rodé mais voilà les grands
derniers rendez-vous avant les jeux vont
nous permettre de régler les derniers
détails la colline dès lors pour qui est
actuellement en chantier puisque le site
justement est en train d'être construit
un dernier mot très rapide sur la Fan
Zone est-ce que les travaux avancent par
rapport à la Fan Zone je le rappelle
pendant les Jeux Olympiques il y aura
une fan zone à 50 ans en Y qui sera
installé sur l'île de loisirs absolument
alors les travaux avancent entre
guillemets on nous venons de publier le
marché de l'appel d'Off pour trouver la
société avec laquelle nous allons
travailler pour organiser ce village qui
sera un club Paris 2024 labellisé comme
tel dans lequel il y aura des écrans
géants qui permettront de suivre toutes
les compétitions en direct mais on
pourra aussi venir manger un morceau
boire un verre assister à un concert le
soir regardez du sport essayez du sport
dans l'esprit de la journée olympique il
y aura beaucoup d'ateliers sportifs avec
les clubs associations du territoire et
même du département pour que la fête
soit complète qu'elle soit pour tout le
monde grand petit qu'on vienne en
famille entre amis que les touristes qui
seront nombreux sur le territoire puisse
aussi en profiter la fin de la fête de
l'olympisme 396 jours avant le début des
Jeux olympiques de Paris 2024 merci
Arnaud courtier merci à vous conseiller
spécial aux Jeux olympiques et
paralympiques pour
Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines et le prochain
rendez-vous et bien sportif dans les
prochaines semaines et bien ce sera le
départ de la dernière étape du Tour de
France le 23 juillet 2023 au Vélodrome
national on va maintenant passer aux
résultats sport
et on va commencer par du tennis on va
parler de notre chouchou Arthur Rinder
cneche tennis hier les qualifications du
tournoi de major composé et face au
jordaniens Abdes la chaîne dad il a
perdu en 3 7 le score 4 6 7 6 6 4 Arthur
hinderkness originaire de
Saint-Germain-en-Laye jouera le tournoi
de Wimbledon dans les prochains jours on
ne connaît pas encore son adversaire
shelbai pour son adversaire un mot de
tennis de table handisport à présent
Lucie au tiers les sourcils chez
skipping et qui s'entraîne à Voisins le
bretonneux était en République tchèque
la semaine dernière la sportive a
terminé deuxième en simple dans la
classe 8 et 2e en double dame elle se
rendra à Taïwan dans les prochains jours
Lucie au tiers devrait participer aux
Jeux paralympiques de Paris en 2024
attrape la deuxième édition de la Coupe
du Monde de trap était organise ce
dimanche 25 juin au complexe Yuri garreg
yuri Gagarine je vais y arriver alors au
programme des matchs à 9 contre 9
pendant une vingtaine de minutes avec
une mi-temps plusieurs l'équipe se sont
inscrites pour la compétition sur le
terrain on a pu voir la Côte d'Ivoire le
Brésil l'Algérie le Maroc la Turquie ou
encore la France au total 210 joueurs
ont participé à la compétition on écoute
l'organisateur Teddy au micro de tv78
l'objectif est de permettre aux gens de
pouvoir vivre en le vivre ensemble
d'être en convivialité et de savoir
qu'on a des origines ça veut dire qu'on
qu'on est français mais en même temps on
a des origines on est fier on va dire de
de nos origines et on essaie de leur
représenter de la meilleure des manières
sur le terrain la Guinée Conakry
l'emporte au tir au but face à la Côte
d'Ivoire une nouvelle coupe du monde de
trappe devrait être programmée l'année
prochaine cette fois-ci les
organisateurs espèrent pouvoir attirer
une équipe des Antilles ou encore des
Portugais et on va maintenant ouvrir une
page de basketball le double champion de
France de Pro A en 2013 et 2017 le
basketteur Jérémy zoli s'est engagé pour
la saison prochaine avec trap le joueur
est avec nous pour en parler bonsoir
Jérémy
bonsoir bonsoir alors vous rejoignez le
club de Trappes déjà un mot pourquoi ce
choix
en fait c'est j'ai cherché à me
rapprocher de la région parisienne et
j'ai un de mes meilleurs amis qui jouait
chez vous c'est Michel epook et en fait
quand je leur ai parlé il m'a dit ben
écoute je vais en parler à mon club et
être à tout de suite montrer l'intérêt
et en fait on s'est rendu compte qu'on
avait vraiment des intérêts communs et
ça c'était vraiment très très
naturellement
alors vous avez 32 ans vous évoluer au
poste d'arrière ou délier vous avez
encore de belles années devant vous 32
ans c'est pas vieux dans le basket-ball
j'arrêtais parce que bon mine d'erreur
j'ai quand même fait 14 ans dans ce
métier dont je pense que c'est déjà pas
mal et aujourd'hui maintenant j'ai une
famille donc l'instabilité qui vient
avec le métier m'arrange pas forcément
donc c'est pour ça que j'ai décidé de
tout doucement aller vers autre chose
votre regard sur le niveau national 3
qu'est-ce que qu'est-ce que vous en
pensez
quelque chose que je connais moyennement
puisque j'ai joué en National 3 quand
j'étais beaucoup plus jeune quand
j'avais 19 ans après j'ai des amis qui
jouent mais je pense que je peux pas me
permettre de trop m'avancer et parler du
niveau alors que ça fait longtemps que
j'ai pas vu un match de Nationale 3 donc
je vais rester je reste assez vague à ce
niveau là
Bordeaux Chalon à Strasbourg Orléans
Jacques Michelet vous qui êtes encore
sur ce sur ce plateau expliquez-nous un
petit peu comment vous avez fait pour le
séduire on voit quand même que Jérémy a
un sacré CV
et bien comme il voulait l'a dit déjà il
y avait un problème géographique et puis
ensuite
je pense que Jérémie a été intéressé par
l'esprit club par le projet de notre
club qui est de faire partager les
valeurs
de favoriser les les jeunes Autochtones
je dirais pour pour le haut niveau et
pour en fait cette
je dirais cette prétention à ce que le
basket de haut niveau il n'est pas
réservé à une évite tout à fait étirée
mais il est il doit être accessible à
tous et notamment au trappistes nous
avons aussi donc non seulement une
équipe de National 3 nous avons été en
deux et en un auparavant mais surtout
nous avons un club de sport qui est
passé de 135 en 2020
à 360 aujourd'hui
ceci montre vraiment le dynamisme et
montre de quelle manière nous concevons
également le haut niveau à savoir une
un exemple une aspiration comme quoi
cette aspiration à cet exemple sont
accessibles pour les jeunes pour les
jeunes de trappes et pour nous parce que
pour nous le basket comme d'ailleurs
l'esprit olympique c'est de faire de la
France et bien une cité sportive une
nation sportive et ça me semble être
vraiment pour nous le la chose la plus
profonde et étant entendu que pour nous
une nation sportive c'est une nation
également de réussite intellectuelle je
ne connais pas de bons sportifs qui ne
sont qu'une main qu'aucun pied ou qu'un
instrument il faut obligatoirement qu'il
y ait une tête bien faite
sans cela il n'y a pas de haut niveau
Jérémy justement par rapport à ce que
dit Jacques Michelet est-ce que vous
souhaitez jouer aussi un rôle par
rapport au club en général aux jeunes
notamment pour et bien les sensibiliser
peut-être au niveau et au obligations
par rapport au niveau
oui ça fait partie des choses qui vont
prendre intéressé dans le discours c'est
que il y avait d'autres équipes de la
région parisienne qui était intéressé et
des fois c'était des projets qui étaient
pas si ambitieux et là je trouvais que
c'était bien de ça c'était juste dans ce
que je voulais puisque je vais avoir du
temps pour mon projet personnel mais
dans le même temps je voulais pas juste
jouer pour jouer là on sent que trap ils
ont envie de construire quelque chose et
j'aime beaucoup aussi le projet qu'ils
ont pour les jeunes parce que j'ai
beaucoup discuté avec leur avec leur
Général Manager en Acer et ce qui j'ai
beaucoup aimé la philosophie qui était
prônée et moi j'ai toujours quelqu'un
qui a toujours apprécié parler avec les
jeunes essayer de transmettre le plus
possible mon expérience donc c'est
quelque chose que je vais essayer de
faire un trap et on va voir ce que ça ça
pourrait être un résultat qui va plaire
à tout le monde à toutes les parties
Jacques comment on fait pour l'intégrer
dans un collectif
Jérémy et bien il faut d'abord avoir les
les valeurs et puis Jérémy vient de
montrer qu'on avait des valeurs communes
ensuite il faut pas que ces valeurs
soient simplement des intentions mais il
faut qu'il les prouver en acte notre
club les a prouvé en acte nous avons
quelques fois fait des des choix qui
n'étaient pas celles de l'optimum de la
de la haute performance pour que
justement ce le sport reste une réalité
locale de façon à ce que en fait le haut
niveau de chacun soit le niveau auquel
chacun peut prétendre et pour cela
s'appuyer bien sûr sur les enseignements
et les exemples les plus forts les plus
ambitieux également parce que l'ambition
fait partie justement
fait vraiment partie de ce de ce projet
l'ambitieux l'ambition d'être au plus
haut niveau que l'on puisse prétendre
chacun alors justement Jérémy quel rôle
vous souhaitez jouer vous comment vous
voyez votre rôle dans le collectif cette
fois-ci vous allez expliquer dans le
club mais maintenant dans le collectif
et puis quels sont vos objectifs
personnels est-ce qu'il y a déjà la
Nationale 2 dans votre tête pour
l'objectif de l'année prochaine
beaucoup de points oui en plus alors
j'ai entendu alors Michael disait il
croit que vous marquez énormément de
points en plus
bon c'est vrai que je c'est gentil mais
c'est vrai que oui effectivement je suis
capable de pouvoir secouer mais ça faut
répondre à la question précédente je
pense pas que forcément qu'il faut qu'on
se dise Jérémy doit s'intégrer mais
c'est à moi plutôt de m'intégrer moi
pour moi le but c'est d'essayer de
d'apporter ce qui pourra aider l'équipe
à ce qu'on puisse gagner puisque moi
j'ai pas d'intérêt à venir briller enfin
aujourd'hui même si je finis mais un
marqueur de la Nationale 3 et qu'on m'en
parle c'est pas très intéressant
moi pour moi le but c'est qu'on puisse
que je puisse aider le club puisque je
trouve que c'est une démarche mutuelle
puisque moi aidé dans mon mec dans mon
projet et moi j'ai aussi les aider dans
leur projet en essayant d'aider le club
à monter donc le but c'est moi de faire
en sorte de trouver où est-ce que moi je
peux être le plus efficace pour l'équipe
en connaissant les forces et les
faiblesses de chacun qu'est-ce que vous
pouvez apporter justement je suppose
votre votre expérience du mieux
professionnel ça peut servir notamment
National 3 oui parce que j'ai comme j'ai
dit j'ai joué 14 ans donc forcément j'ai
joué avec beaucoup de joueurs avec
beaucoup de types de personnalités j'ai
déjà gagné des choses et je sais
justement ce que ça ça implique de
gagner et puis aussi aujourd'hui bon
comme je le disais c'est j'arrête j'ai
arrêté le basket professionnel pas parce
que physiquement je pouvais plus donc
aujourd'hui même sur le terrain je pense
que je peux apporter à plusieurs égards
c'est à dire que je peux construire pour
les autres comme je peux secouer comme
je peux toujours défendre donc il y a
beaucoup de choses que je peux faire
pour pouvoir essayer d'aider l'équipe à
gagner sachant que trap a terminé 9e de
la poule F cette année en National 3
peut-être un mot pour les supporters
Jérémy qui peuvent nous écouter
j'espère que il y aura le plus
d'ambiance possible et que le plus de
des gens vont nous suivre et je sais que
souvent dans beaucoup de clubs dans
laquelle je suis passé ça passe pas des
victoires donc je sais plus on gagnera
plus on aura du monde donc nous on va
essayer de faire le travail pour gagner
plus de match et j'espère que ils sont
là pour nous encourager dans les matchs
les plus chauds pour qu'on aille
chercher ses victoires difficiles
non Michael dans quelques minutes on va
parler de Victor web benyama justement
peut-être un mot Jérémy et Jacques sur
Victor one byama phénomène chez lesien
Yves Linois qui rejoint les Spurs ça y
est c'est officialisé depuis la semaine
dernière
je crois que c'est très bien pour lui
c'est très bien également pour ça
l'ensemble de ces formateurs
je trouve que ce jeune garçon une
maturité je sais que c'est un peu un
lieu commun maintenant ça se divertit
mais une maturité tout à fait étonnante
pour son âge et c'est vraiment en ce
sens que nous pensons le sportif en
général je lui espère vraiment beaucoup
de réussite et puis pourquoi pas qui
nous reviennent Jérémy vous qui avez
côtoyé ce type de joueur sur les
parquets votre regard sur Victor
webmanyama
puisqu'il était au club de Nanterre en
même temps que moi puisqu'il a évolué un
interrogène et j'ai rejoué l'année
dernière contre lui aussi j'ai vu les
deux dernières années contre lui donc je
connais
très bien mais je le connais quand même
et effectivement comme le président l'a
dit c'est un jeune qui est extrêmement
mature pour sondage parce que là il y a
énormément de pression sur ces épaules
puisque là il est rend quand même déjà
dans l'histoire c'est le premier
Français à être le premier de la graft
donc c'est déjà extraordinaire
maintenant
il va être beaucoup regardé il va être
beaucoup suivi donc ça va être beaucoup
d'apprentissage pour lui parce que c'est
très très dur il y aura énormément de
pression et il va falloir qu'il apprenne
à gérer le haut et les bas mais je pense
qu'il est bien entouré et qu'il est
peut-être bien fait donc j'ai peu connu
c'était le meilleur si ces futurs
adversaires américains nous regardent
quel conseil vous pouvez leur donner
pour défendre sur lui
quand je vois son profil je pense que
pour l'instant tout ce qui peut faire
c'est c'est que je suis avec lui parce
que bon il est jeune il a 18 ans donc il
va encore beaucoup se développer
physiquement mais pour l'instant il est
pas encore assez surtout comparativement
à la NBA puisqu'on parle des des plus
grands athlètes du monde donc
aujourd'hui leur seul chance c'est
d'essayer de jouer physiquement parce
que sinon ça va être très très compliqué
pour eux
merci Jérémy d'être d'avoir passé un
moment dans le 7 8 et Merci à VOUS
Jacques Michelet je rappelle président
du club de basketball de trappes et un
dernier mot justement de basketball et
Michael nidoro avec Victor webmail oui
le nouvel ailier fort des centres
Antonio Spurs Victor webmanyama après la
décision de ne pas prendre part à la
campagne estivale de l'équipe de France
qui doit se disputer la Coupe du monde
les Viennois draftés en première
position la semaine dernière expliquait
que c'était un sacrifice nécessaire en
termes de développement il a également
dit que ce n'était pas prudent pour sa
santé il ne ferme toutefois pas la porte
au bleu et au prochain Jeux Olympiques à
Paris en 2024 et maintenant on va parler
de CrossFit nickel vous êtes allés au
Vélodrome national à des vêtements
CrossFit oui on va prendre la direction
du Vélodrome national de 50 ans en
Yvelines j'ai gardé quelques couleurs
d'ailleurs de de ce passage sur ce vélo
donc national de
Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines sous le soleil
sous la chaleur pendant trois jours la
structure accueillie le CrossFit slodon
2023 l'une des plus grandes compétitions
de CrossFit en France à montage de
Thomas Fletcher
[Musique]
des muscles des épreuves des sportifs
qui vont au bout de même bienvenue au
French slorden de 2023 la plus grande
compétition de CrossFit en France un
rendez-vous organisé pour la troisième
fois consécutive au Vélodrome national
de 50 ans en Yvelines l'événement monte
en cuisson sur la courbe est croissante
en termes de public de jauge et
d'athlètes cette année c'est plus de 800
ans d'athlètes internationaux qui se
sont réunis à 50 ans en Yvelines c'est
une vraie communauté qui s'implante
d'année en année au coeur du territoire
de Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines donc c'est
un véritable état d'esprit que nous on
cautionne qu'on aimerait encourager et
développer au fil des ans une communauté
qu'il faut accueillir dans les
meilleures conditions ici tout est pensé
pour plaire au 9000 visiteurs présents
sur les trois jours à côté des arènes
sportives un village a été installé pour
le rendez-vous on retrouve des dizaines
de stands et notamment des boutiques de
vêtements spécialisés dans le CrossFit
et les CrossFitters en profitent pour
s'équiper pour la compétition
après voilà toutes les brassières ils
savent les marques savent très bien nous
faire craquer sur des modèles Florent ce
qui nous les faut tous le CrossFit un
mode de vie quelques mètres plus loin on
retrouve même de la nourriture aux
protéines pour les participants une idée
lancée l'année dernière par cette
entrepriseur francilien c'est un produit
que j'ai pas mal présenté dans le monde
du Crossfit et qui plaît énormément dans
le monde entier donc voilà donc c'était
la raison pour laquelle je suis là pour
que les gens ils se fasse plaisir qu'ils
puissent manger et en même temps que ça
réponde à leurs besoins tant que sportif
des pâtisseries qui permettront
peut-être aux athlètes de performer dans
l'arène ici les 800 sportifs enchaînent
les épreuves de force tout au long de la
journée sous la chaleur le but est
d'être le plus régulier possible pour
marquer des points
pour pas faire de contre-performance
et bah forcément il y a des épreuves qui
sont durs mais en même temps on est là
pour ça quoi je pense qu'il faut être
complet partout parce que le CrossFit
c'est un mélange de gym de cardio et de
force et quand tu es complet que tu as
ces trois qualités c'est le mieux les
champions les catégories et les temps
remporté les sommes allongés jusqu'à
15000 € l'événement ne devrait pas
revenir l'année prochaine pour une
quatrième édition dans les Yvelines à
cause des Jeux olympiques de 2024 mais
les organisateurs prévoient déjà un
retour sur site après les JO bon Mickaël
c'est l'objet c'était l'occasion aussi
de se préparer pour le parcours de la
flamme olympique et peut-être devenir le
relayeur
cette matinée en tout cas merci pour ces
résultats sportifs Michael et après
cette page sport et bien on va te jeter
un dernier regard sur la météo de demain
[Musique]
et demain matin le ciel yvelinois sera
en partie couvert avec quelques
éclaircies dans la matinée les
températures seront déjà chaudes avec 17
degrés dans la partie nord et centrale
du département et 16 degrés dans le
sud-yvelines dans l'après-midi même
prévisions par rapport à la matinée les
nuages seront toujours présents mais le
soleil fera quelques apparitions côté
température il fera 24 degrés à
Mantes-la-Jolie ou dans et Rambouillet
puis 23 degrés à Versailles et c'est la
fin du 7 8 merci de nous avoir suivi et
à bientôt sur TV 78
[Musique]